we do have this one pulled up and it's
not funny and I'm kind of like reluctant
to pull it up because we're laughing
here we're making fun of people and now
we have the story where it's like the
world's gonna end check this out from
the guardian U.S joins Germany in
sending tanks to Ukraine as Biden Hale's
United effort president land's
unflagging commitment to Ukraine as
officials approve 31 M1 Abrams Tanks to
add to Germany's 14 leopard to a6s
is this world war three I mean you don't
got to call world war three but I mean
NATO is at war with Russia this is not
Ukraine I mean we are the ones it's fair
it's fair to say it's escalation
I mean I I don't I mean Russia says it's
world war three right they already used
that term they're they're already well
they're TV personalities all over Russia
are saying we're on World War III
already one guy came out again it's like
the fifth time some TV personality has
done it and said fire the nukes already
just start firing nukes the the the fact
that there's tanks being given to
Ukraine that is going to be
justification to the Russians to
escalate they're going to say the that
NATO is escalating because it's Germany
and the US they're going to look at it
in France they're going to look at it
like an escalation and they're going to
do something there will be some response
every time we do anything that helps
Ukraine Russia takes that as an attack
on them and they use that as
justification to do more things so y'all
I don't know what they're strong are we
really helping Ukraine by prolonging the
war though I don't think so but that's
just me it's a question of are we are we
preventing Russia from taking more
control of Ukraine is that is that help
I kind of think the U.S I look at this
way Ukraine is a border country with
Russia right the United States is on the
other side of the planet and the U.S is
sending weapons and agitating imagine if
Russia was sending weapons to Mexico and
then like cartels were attacking the
southern border and trying to take
stretches of the Rio Grande or something
well Russians are the black people of
white people
what is that what does that what does
that mean
no I mean look woke people say Slavic
people are are people of color yeah well
I mean that's technically you're right
like even look at it from a resource
perspective you know Russia's the Africa
of Europe
they're very minimal rich
right like oil like very big yeah that
cold though yeah so if you look at how
Rush uh how Africa is treated Russia is
getting the Africa treatment we got to
go in we gotta colonize we have to take
your assets we have to divvy it up it's
just beautiful communism you think we're
gonna go into Russia too you know the
U.S goes into Russia I well when you say
into Russia right it's it's
first thing now we have to understand
what
hollandizing what you first do is you
colonize the culture
and as we talked about before you
discredit the witness so you discredit
the current culture you make Putin look
bad you make the culture and then you
attack the root
of Russia which is Orthodox Christianity
they're already attacking that so
there's a cultural colonization that's
happening and if you can uproot that
everything else sort of falls into place
but Russia is definitely a target of
some group of people on this planet most
of them running financial institutions I
believe because they're the same ones
behind situations like FTX right large
financial institution pumping into and
then I didn't say that you said that
um
but we saw the financial institutions
that were involved in the FTX election
Ukraine
triangle you see what I'm saying but
there's always been that sort of history
between America and Russia for example
we talk about uh the Civil War
the North had Russia as an ally so
there's always been that tie right also
I mean that that Britain too didn't they
no
uh that was uh the South had a
France and Britain against right against
them right oh you said the North had
Russia against them had Russia with them
with them but but then France and uh in
the UK were with the north as well South
the the the UK and France were with the
South correct okay well they were like
they were like playing both sides right
trying to see well absolutely yeah yeah
yeah they were selling stuff I think I
think actually yeah I think the South
was trying to sell cotton to the UK
mm-hmm correct yeah yeah yeah yeah so
there was some of that and Russia comes
in and plays this role as hey we're
going to be the great equalizer of some
sort and that's how we get the whole
exchange of Alaska because they own that
and that's how that thing happens right
correct but you got to remember Russia
was a world superpower under uh Nicholas
right that was before the Russian
Revolution came about and who financed
the Russian Revolution I say on here but
everybody knows who did that right so
you see this tie of money behind all
these things real quick this is from my
book The Patriot report I'm asking a
conspiracy of money award available now
on Amazon and hoteljesus.com
um but I've tracked back you know this
whole thing about the central banking
system whatever whatever but I always
see Russia pop up and I see Russia as
being the one place that this financial
Elite has not quite conquered so I think
they want to it and then you
know slowly grab its resources
if you take a look at uh history of the
region with the Middle East with Europe
one big component which it's interesting
because I hear in the media they're
reporting as a conspiracy theory it's
the the natural gas Monopoly it's gas
prom it's Nordstrom it's the cutter
turkey pipeline I talk about it all the
time because it's like I think it's the
key in what's happening NATO wants to
get cheap energy into Europe Europe
demands it Syria says no the U.S is is
very fortunate that Syria then goes into
Civil War and of course we oppose the
Assad regime who said outright we will
not let you build the cutter turkey
Pipeline and uh conveniently wanted to
build an alternate pipeline that would
do the same thing strengthening Russia's
energy Monopoly in Europe and then all
of a sudden you get barisma with Joe
Biden former CIA director and these
interests working for an energy company
in Ukraine
nordstream 2 blows up you can just
imagine stink bug did you yeah you're
going to regret that yeah absolutely
it's gonna smell real bad now
Chinese books it is that's what you
don't you can't smash them bro really
yeah it's gonna be like ammonia here in
a minute yeah it's Mel yeah it smells
like ammonia is that what it is it's
like are we wrestling today that smells
like cilantro it doesn't smell like
cilantro no it's it's gonna smell real
bad though yeah yeah they release this
oil
stink bugs man yeah they're called stink
bugs oh that's what they call those
that's the thing I call it the Chinese
bugs they are Chinese bugs right yeah
they came over here in the 70s or
whatever and they're you can't get rid
of them right yeah yeah we actually uh
we looked it up it's 1996 that's what
they said oh 96 well yeah you uh we
called the Exterminator spraying does
nothing yeah because in China they have
wasps that eat them but you don't have
lobster yeah there's no natural predator
yeah yeah right anyway we're talking
about we're talking about Nordstrom too
that Nordstrom 2 blows up yeah and then
right you know they blame Russia for
blowing up their own Pipeline and it's
like yeah Putin did it yeah so it's so
it the the whole thing is
it's interesting because the argument
made about why the EU needs to exist is
to compete with China that's what they
say they say they want to create a
powerful economic block they can compete
with China because China is growing so
rapidly I call BS on that Joe Biden was
involved in selling natural gas from
Louisiana to China with Hunter Biden
that was just revealed in the hunter
Biden laptop story exclusive emails
released Daily Mail covered the story
Joe Biden there's an email saying I've
organized the meeting for Joe and Hunter
to do the sale and it was natural gas
from Louisiana to China why are we
selling energy to China
so they say Europe wants to compete with
it I call BS I think it's
ideological I think it is control I
think you got a bunch of powerful
interests the United States went to
China
and said what you're doing with this
communism using Market Market systems
dictatorship is what that what we want
to do so the United States has been
trying to implement Chinese style
communism here and in other countries
it's a lot more than just that I don't
think it's so simple I think energy
absolutely plays a role they do want to
get cheaper energy into Europe they do
want lower energy costs but Russia is
their principal villain not China China
has the ideology they like Russia
doesn't what's the incentive for Biden
and the rest of these guys to go along
with the Chinese agenda are they
thinking about themselves or is it some
I think what you basically have is
there's evil people who do things for
ideological reasons okay who employ
selfish psychotic individuals who do
things for personal reasons okay so Joe
Biden's the kind of guy who says I'm
gonna sell energy to China everyone else
be damned and then you have ideologues
who are like who are they the ideologues
yeah I it's hard to say who is who is
they though right yeah
it's hard to say because I'm walking out
of here man we made it an hour in
everybody he's the new record holder so
the reason I say it's hard to say is not
that it's a censorship question and
people expect me to say like Jews or
something no I'm talking about like the
Davos group okay powerful corporate
interests these are people of all
different backgrounds there you can call
them Global Elites you can call them uh
CEOs you could but it's hard to quantify
exactly how you group these people other
than it is the people of means and power
around the world who don't want to lose
use it who birds of a feather flock
together they have big big business big
business big business big government
uh all that kind of stuff big lizard
maybe maybe even lizards yeah we don't
know but but a lot of people say the
world economic Forum the Davos group
yeah and it's like that's that's that's
simplistic that's where a lot of the I
think the employees hang out we I would
I would say you know some people have
said like it's the Illuminati as a
catch-all term for powerful Global
interests I'd say that it is a
semi-emergent phenomenon meaning I don't
think that there is like the order of
the Illuminati you know that actually
meets and sits down at their meeting was
a big sense as Illuminati what I think
it is is a Hydra
you've got all these big corporations
they are interested in maintaining that
power and that power is maintained
through rigid control of the of the
planet which means Henry Kissinger I
think Ian points out limited Warfare
meaning they want some more they sell
weapons they don't want to know War
so there's a there's a degree of control
they have to have in a lot of things
they don't have total control though
they're just special interests and the
reason I say semi-semia Merchant is
emergent meaning a phenomenon that
happens over time naturally and I say
only semi because you certainly have
powerful special interests who will meet
and say hey
we need to move these tanks what are we
doing it's like salmon Ukraine let's get
it let's get a conflict of I mean look
at the stock for the companies that
operate the stuff now I'm not saying
definitively that conspiracy theory is
true I'm saying yeah there absolutely
are powerful CEOs who meet with
government officials and say we've got
to move shirts out of this country what
can we do and the government says look
we'll work I have this beautiful War
laid out for you maybe that's a little
far but but I'll I'll give a shout out
to Matt Gates
who said
I said you're going to get a bill to
break a big Tech and then they're gonna
you know get put options on he goes that
actually happened they had a bill moving
through Congress to break up big Tech
Paul Pelosi bought the dip and then the
bills died in their tracks wow and then
of course the stock goes up that's the
kind of thing I'm talking about it's not
that's not an emergency I'll just
introduce the Pelosi act to stop uh
exactly yeah yeah I've seen that but
here here what ultimately what I think
is this CEO of a Fortune 500 company
he's trying to sell as many vaccines as
possible he hears he he lobbies the
government give us a guaranteed contract
and the government says
let's talk you're gonna get lobbies so
let's talk right they're gonna this is
what the this came out of the Veritas
thing just now the uh the guy was saying
basically I think this came out of the
Veritas thing you think these government
employees who are regulating big Pharma
are going to be mean to them when
they're expecting a job afterwards right
the lobbyist doesn't just say I'll
donate to your campaign he says you know
we're big fans of the work you do we
know you believe in helping people of
the world maybe once you're uh you know
what you retire you know we could talk
about a nice package maybe there's a fit
for you come on the board maybe maybe a
couple million dollar a year salary if
of course we think that you actually
care about this stuff yeah that what
ends up happening then is
the guy takes over this company
this big Pharma company he's not
abducted into a conspiracy he doesn't go
to a meeting and they sit him down and
they make him walk through paddles and
he gets veeden or whatever he's a guy
who cuts the company and he's told hey
if you want to make that billion dollars
this year and get your 25 million bonus
we gotta sell more product is there a
way we can get the government the
biggest buyer to buy it which is
possible let's send the lobbyists to
convince them mandates are the way to go
yeah and then you get these things so
you're a communist me
I mean you just basically said that this
is uh you know capitalist greed
that's like that's corporatism yeah it
says corporate greed
Corp yeah I don't know I don't know if
you say this about making money I called
it an emergency but we got to move
products isn't it fascism no no no hold
on hold on this is important I don't
think I don't know if greed is the word
used to describe it that's why I say
it's an emergent phenomenon right it's
power too but look at this way
it's it's because you said bonus you
said bonuses is a financial incentive
but it's not the human machine it's the
it's the it's the uh it's beyond the
human machine man no no no no
timcast.com is a company yeah
timcast.com needs a certain amount of
money every week to maintain this
company right the person who is trying
to maximize Tim cast product isn't
thinking I want to myself he's thinking
I need to meet these deadlines and kpis
exactly so in order to do that and do my
job I might need to call somebody in
government so you get big Pharma and
it's not necessarily the CEO saying I
want to make a billion dollars for
myself yeah but the bonus plays a role
obviously I mentioned that a lot of it
is the Guy saying look we're looking at
a down forecast our Stock's gonna take a
hit the shareholders are going to get
pissed yeah we gotta figure out a
revenue stream and someone says look
this covet thing
there's talk of mandates we should be on
that 100 percent it's the right thing
for the people and it'll help us secure
contracts to keep the company running
yeah and then Tristan walks and he goes
I got a great idea what we're going to
do is we're going to create a whole
bunch of multivariant mutant viruses and
we can sell more vaccines it is how many
grains of sand make a heap is the
banality of evil it is people like him
who are saying
they're justifying it to themselves but
you know what the reality is some of
these people know what they're doing is
evil they know they are cogs in a
machine that is destructive but my point
ultimately is when it comes to the
entirety of the the system as it's
orchestrated I do not believe there is a
singular group of people or individual
who's sitting there saying throwing this
mustache being like you know how we're
going to take over the world it people
come and go it's a it's a monster it's
an amorphous blob empowered by all of
the different people who say
look I'm not an avalanche I'm just a
snowflake Avalanche was coming long
before I got here that's what I see the
Avalanche doesn't blame itself I'm sorry
the snowflake doesn't blame itself for
the Avalanche but each and every time
some Global leader or some powerful
executive joins in these meetings and
they say two things happen the
ideological pressure and the economic
pressure one how do I meet my deadlines
to make sure my company doesn't fail
because the shareholders the employees
are counting on me government mandated
contracts two is the ideological
pressure you ever hear that story so let
me ask you a question look real quick
let me just sorry I'll finish this point
you ever hear that story they did where
they put a bunch of chips in chips in a
room they put a ladder in the middle
room with fruit on top chimp walks over
there's five chimps climbs the ladder
fire hose comes out sprays them all the
chimps get sprayed down
chip climbs tries climb the ladder again
boom they all get sprayed down they
learn stay the away from that ladder
they take one chimp out they put one
Chimp in new chimp is looking around
like what am I doing in here walks over
to the ladder the other chimps run up
grab them and throw them down and start
beating him up because he's going to get
us sprayed right one by one they replace
all the old chips
now they got five chimps who have never
been sprayed with the fire hose any one
of them goes near that ladder they get
beat up why that's the way we do things
yeah that's I think a large component of
the ideological capture that happens
with people at the top so you're saying
that there's this corporate
fascism thing phenomenon that you
mentioned right
and I don't want to dispute that but who
killed JFK
I don't know
it was Charlie he said it was a CIA
Charlie
wow he then went on to say didn't he say
that they went after Nixon too because
he was trying to figure out who killed
JFK Tucker's been going off yeah but
yeah I think he knew there was something
in the files or something like that so
how does all that tie in right if we got
the corporate thing happen in Temple's
phenomenon why is the CIA you know these
other groups involved in are they part
of that corporate thing or are these not
just corporates government power so
here's what happens why does the CAA get
formed it's it's my my fear is that
people ascribe to conspiracy that which
is an emergent human phenomenon which is
dangerous that we need to recognize the
power power coalescence so you get you
know the FBI I think uh what what did
the FBI start as I forgot I did this
whole thing researching it before was
the FBI was called something else right
look at what it is today yeah right I
mean people don't start these things
intending them for intending for them to
become monsters yeah but they do so you
think there's people like struck may be
in position of power who are abusing
this power absolutely okay I think what
I mean to say is
there are people there there's we'll
call it the the the super liminal the
limit on the subliminal you know as The
Simpsons joke reference there are people
who know they're bad people and want
power but I think that's there's not
that many of them there's a lot and you
don't need that many in positions of
power to get an evil group of people
destroying the world you then have
people who know that what they're doing
is kind of bad but they think I'm more
powerful here for good even though so I
remember hearing about like the CEO of
shell or something telling activists I
want to save the world too I'm more
effective as the CEO in doing good so
they recognize in their own mind yeah
bad things are happening because of what
I do but I'm trying and then you have
the people who are totally oblivious who
are like everybody get on the freight
freight car I got no idea why you're
going there where are you going there
but I'm Gonna Make sure you do yeah and
they're contributing to that evil
that's crazy
that's absolutely insane bro so
I'm trying to put all those pieces
together you don't think that there's a
board table uh of Illuminati that are
making decisions behind the scenes
the answer to that question is how do
you think they got a group chat and they
say hey what are we going to do now
they're on top hold on hold on the
answer to that is half yes okay of
course there's a board meeting where
powerful rich people are meeting up but
there's no induction there's no name you
know how they always throw out the name
like Rockefellers yeah of course of
course Rothschild but that just means
rich people and wealthy families and
those Rich families have changed you now
have Jeff Bezos who owns the Washington
Post he wants to sell it so is he an
Illuminati if you're if you're saying
Illuminati as in a nebulous idea of the
powerful Elites who control the planet
yes absolutely oh Jeff Bezos Illuminati
okay what about Elon Musk I would say
yes
so okay so we have Bill Gates I think we
could throw him in there oh absolutely
okay Bezos is Zuckerberg in there yes
yes yeah yeah yeah what about Jack
Dorsey Jack Dorsey I'd say yes
absolutely really even after but but you
got to understand it there's not a
membership list right we're using
Illuminati as a vague term to represent
the most powerful people in the world
okay who meet with each other and decide
how to move their chessboard pieces of
course all these people are playing the
game are there good guys and bad guys
yes yes Elon Musk is in an interesting
position is he a good guy or a bad guy
that's tough to say he's got factories
in China he's defended China he's posted
good things about the Chinese Communist
party but in the United States he says
good things about Freedom he pushes back
he uh you know on the establishment he
calls out Democrats so a lot of people
in the U.S are cheering Free Speech Free
Speech yay but what about his business
dealings in China yeah I mean I mean
we're not We're not gonna sit here and
defend the Chinese Communist party but
Elon Musk has said nice things about
them then you gotta look
powerful people
whether whether they intend to or not
make big moves yeah big moves yeah so
when I say Zuckerberg Gates what I'm
basically saying is at the cream of the
crowd at the top of the top these people
birds of a feather flock together
they're going to hang out they're going
to have similar ideas and similar
experiences they may not completely
agree but they can move mountains so
when we see big moves happening people
on the bottom say it's a conspiracy
they're plotting and it's like
technically that's true right wealthy
powerful and corporate government Elites
are meeting together are planning things
together but it's not like they wear
dark robes and draw pentagrams on the
ground and then paddle each other to to
induct them into this illumination while
they're making the decisions that kind
of party happens after the decisions are
made don't get me wrong there there are
those weird parties that happen that's
what I mean it's what I'm saying is
there may be groups that go to like
Bohemian Grove do that weird Malik stuff
yeah which I'm sure you've heard of but
the people the Davos group people things
like that I know people who have gone to
the world economic Forum they do not
regularly go to board meetings they go
once a year to hear what other people
have to say yeah share their ideas but
if you get 2 000 corporate Elites and
government Elites and they all start
sharing their ideas together it starts
to starts to come together their Cycles
start to synchronize
you know who some people say is an
Illuminati oh temple in the Illuminati
yeah they say you're part of this group
of evil decision makers are you an
Illuminati template I'm putting you on a
spot right now nope nope uh I'm not I
guess unfortunately because I thought I
was about to ask you well can I get in
no no
interesting things happening with the
decentralization of power and media and
resources so now you're ending up with
companies that probably much to the
Chagrin of these uh uh powerful Elites
who want to control things you're
getting people like us who are finding
ways to navigate through the cracks and
build power that is very hard for them
to deal with so you're building like an
ALT Illuminati yeah well no but maybe we
should I did say this on the show before
I was like can't we do the opposite can
we have like a group of activists come
together for meritocracy Liberty
personal freedom personal responsibility
and then start like making books and
giving them to schools and doing stuff
like that you know what I mean well
Hotel Nation that's what we're involved
with homeschooling well I believe in
homeschooling but I'm saying make the
hotel book and get it and get it in
schools you talk about counter
propaganda
or just literally propaganda yeah
Freedom propaganda yeah I like that idea
you guys make the books go to schools
and then tell the schools like you're
not racist are you you're not okay then
put our book in your curriculum the book
will be like Freedom Liberty personal
responsibility Uncle Hotel what would
you put in a book if we were to put a
book out and say this is the most
important thing we want to tell people
or teach children you know especially
with CRT drag story time right now what
would you put in a book
what I put in a book yeah like what
would be you know the one thing you
think children need to need to be taught
to because I look at it as like counter
Marxism right because that's really
what's counter-revolutionary yes yeah
absolutely you're now you're talking my
language yeah you know what they need to
put in the grifter Hall of Fame potep
Jesus number one there tomorrow right
there thegrifties.com greatest grifter
of all time vote for me 50s.com do you
nominate yourself you're like I have to
be on this list yeah that's awesome I'm
in the site I got access of course I
thought I've been into myself I'm trying
to win I think I just got passed by um
Dan can you pull it up grifties.com can
you pull up who's winning right now
again
pull that up and what's happening yeah
grifties.com gr i f t i e s
no uh take out the it's just grifties oh
it's no the no the yeah put put that up
there let's see who's winning right now
Eliza blue no that's the newest oh
that's the newest nominee okay
Eliza blew at 14. you're number one
number two oh
shut up who's Chile de Castro I don't
know The Young Turks number five I'm
impressed oh no no that says what is
that says newest nominees number five
what does that mean oh because they're
groups is that what it is yeah it is
groups yeah okay Nation hotep's been
told you you guys are trying the
grifties is number one let's go that's a
good one Reddit look at this number
three drifted in Greta that's impressive
Uncle Grand in a hotel with it Alex
Stein number nine Crowder number ten
Eliza blue is there at number 14 it's a
new entry Vladimir zelenski at 12. uh
Michael rapaport's in there gruesome
news look at that all right I was on
there at one point I was pretty high up
there but I guess I got knocked off you
gotta nominate Temple nominate Temple
right now on grifties.com I don't know
if I deserve it to be honest absolutely
absolutely you do you deserve it because
I'm able to grift off of you
you make grifting capable or possible
for a lot of people you've got to be
acknowledged for your contribution the
grift amplification culture the grift
economy
next year I might be able to make it I I
do think I gotta be honest I don't know
if you should be number two why I should
be number one right no I don't know if
you should be on the list at all why
because I think making the grifties and
talking about it is not grifting thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time